es el mundial más caro de la historia
datos de la consultora de load y otras
publicaciones financieras revelan Una
cantidad exorbitante para lograr acatar
2022 al menos 220 mil millones de
dólares desglosados en estadios e
infraestructura necesaria para llevar a
cabo el evento deportivo que más
pasiones mueven el mundo algo que llama
la atención en este asunto son las
ganancias tan solo 17 mil millones de
dólares de entrada para un país pequeño
con casi 3 millones de habitantes pero
realmente rico en gas Cuál es Entonces
el rédito de realizar un evento tan caro
quería abrirse al mundo exterior por lo
que asegurar la Copa del Mundo podría
verse como el apogeo de esa ambición
Qatar 2022 es más costoso que su
antecesor Rusia 2018 multiplicado por 10
y sobrepasando con creces el realizado
en Brasil 2014 hasta el momento la
apertura no se observa en su totalidad
aspectos la cultura chocan con los
estándares occidentales a decir de
expertos todo este gasto no es más que
un lavado deportivo o Sport washing dos
palabras que se aplican a las naciones
que cuentan con un cuestionado
prontuario de violaciones a los derechos
humanos o direcciones autocráticas y que
utilizan su gran poder adquisitivo para
posicionarse en el mundo del deporte con
otra cara un ejemplo fundamental son los
equipos europeos que pertenecen a las
cabezas coronadas del Golfo